let's talk about the new villains in
Picard season three because
it's a little confusing welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so pecan season three is nearly upon us
it's going to be Aaron on Powerman Plus
on February 16th and I have to say I am
incredibly excited it looks brilliant
but with a note of caution Picard season
one looked brilliant and it disappointed
in Picard season 2 looked even more
brilliant and not even more disappointed
so let's hope third time looking and
Alex kurtzman and the rest of that team
including Terry mattalis as shown can
pull something at their backsides to
surprise us and make us all joyful a
series that the Next Generation crew and
those actors truly deserve
but in this video I'm going to be
looking at the villains because we know
of at least three currently first of all
law is going to be making a return now
law looks like he's got skin and he
looks like an old robot makes absolutely
no sense currently but we actually don't
know what the background of that is now
the last time we saw a law at the end of
Descent Part Two he was defeated by data
we saw data Express his love for his
brother and then deactivate him we know
that he was then dismantled and at some
point the emotionship that law used was
damaged that motion ship data then used
during the movie Generations
so how on Earth does law go from being
dismantled and you can only imagine some
sort of federation research facility to
now wandering around wherever the hell
they are to now being a threat to
Jean-Luc Picard and the rest of the TNG
crew now I'm a little bit confused on
why laforge immediately recognizes um
the Android as law I would have thought
it would make more sense for it to be
before but it doesn't through the window
we see from the trailer that laforge
immediately recognizes him now it's also
obvious that law seems to have human
skin possibly
um but it's definitely aged now how on
Earth that happened I'm they're going to
have to again be very clever to explain
the other villain that we see
momentarily is Moriarty now as I've
spoken in other videos about this but
Moriarty the last time we saw him was on
a data Crystal aboard the Enterprise D
now we assumed it was still there and in
that case crashed somehow on Earth again
has that character got into this new
series but also and more importantly how
are the Moriarty character and law
connected
now my initial thinking was well this is
going to be like a Sinister Six kind of
thing where all the bad guys group
together to try to defeat the good guy
in this case Jean-Luc Picard but that
would be a little bit overly simple and
you know I don't really see how that
works but when we start thinking about
who the main villain is maybe that gives
us a few hints on actually who the vat
is and why these other characters are
being dragged through Captain vatic
seems to be the main protagonist in the
new season of Picard she's able this
vessel the shrike that is pretty
menacing and seems to from what we see
in the trailer take on the USS Titan and
actually is a major threat from the
trailer it looks like the strike is
coming down on the Titan and the Titan
is getting its ass handed to it now we
don't know much about Captain vanic at
all
um nothing really has been released yet
but the couple of things that we get
from the trailer is that Picard knows
there's a threat at one point in the
train only he says we've got to run and
seven of nine to advances from what and
then the strike attacks and we see the
Titan trying to leg it we see another
scene with Will Riker screaming fire
everything we've got we again assume
that is genuinely during a battle with
the strike but we don't know soon so who
could this Captain vatic be well there
are a few theories and I'm just gonna
pick the three that I think are most
likely first of all could it be actually
a member of Picard's crew from the past
somebody that felt wrong by something
Picard did maybe it was a crew member
during the Battle of wolf 359 or
something like that that got injured or
even maybe assimilated but let's talk
about that in a second but either way if
this was a member of the Federation an
old crew member that wants desperate
revenge against Picard and potentially
the rest of the TNG crew then that might
make sense and might be a connection to
why we've then seen law and Moriarty
because this is a crew member that was
potentially there during those incidents
and is not necessarily bringing those
villains together in a cynicist kind of
way is a team up but maybe in a just as
a way is punishing Picard reminding him
of his sins the other reason I like is
that potentially this vatic is actually
an ex-borg now one possibility again is
that she was assimilated during the
attack on the enterprise we know that
the Enterprise in its very first
encounter with the Borg lost several
crew there was also obviously the Battle
of all 359 where Picard was the
commander of the Borg assault if there
was somebody aboard one of those vessels
it was an assimilated and for some
reason managed to escape and become
unassimilated like we saw again in
Picard season one having all the
technology removed and becoming a human
being again it would 100 explain why she
is out for such blood but it might also
explain where the strike comes from
because maybe that vessel is a borg ship
the third theory that seems to be quite
popular is that maybe she's an augment
like Khan and that this whole series of
Picard season 3 is actually really just
kind of a remake of The Wrath of Khan
now that is a theory I'm kind of on
board with in a way but only because I
always felt that Picard Series 2 felt a
lot like the Voyage Home to me the way
it was filmed the way it was put
together and there was actually little
even little clips and nods back to the
original movie remember the the ACT
actually returned with the stereo on the
bus and all that sort of thing there was
a very strong connections to the Voyage
Home in season two of Picard perhaps
there's going to be very strong
connections between the Wrath of Khan
and season three of Picard and if that's
the case then perhaps his vatic is an
augment that was related to Khan in some
way or perhaps related to song
now season two Adam's Song seemed to be
working towards creative augmented human
beings and we know other relations of
nunyan song that created data actually
did create superhumans thou something
their research moved towards a lot and
we actually saw a file called the Khan
project towards the end of season two of
Picard
so perhaps this again is going to be
something that's linked to season two
and then again maybe we could make a
little bit more sense of some of the
events of season two all of the stuff
really about Adam's Song and his
character really was kind of irrelevant
to the rest of the plot it was just sort
of happening while Picard was trying to
save the universe it didn't really
affect the overall story at all but Q
was still very interested in random song
and we have to wonder why perhaps that
whole bit in season two was leading up
to what's going to happen in season
three and you're gonna have to
understand that to understand the events
of season three
any of these options I think are a
possibility and there's also obviously
the option there's just something
completely random that we've never heard
of but that seems to be unlikely one of
the big things Alex kurtzman has always
tried to do throughout all of the new
track is throwing Easter eggs and nods
back to the original series now you can
say what you like about Alex kurtzman
and the way he messes around with Canon
and he does a lot but he does work
really hard to then try to make fans
happy make trekkies Happy by throwing in
these little nods I don't believe for
one second that vatic won't have some
sort of connection to something we
already know about and it's going to be
something I think quite big
so let's see what happens and we're not
going to have to wait very long because
as I say Picard season 3 is going to be
airing on February 16th on Paramount
Plus
so guys getting to comes to tell me
exactly what you think about the
prospect of Picard season 3 and what do
you think this villain vanish is doing
where does she come from and why is she
dragging Moriarty and law along with it
again to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think as always if
you're new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
because you'll never miss any of our new
videos and if you really want to support
the Channel please consider hitting the
join button as always please stay safe
I'll see you next time
[Music]